je vous ramène début de l'année 2020
colomb est chef propriétaire de
restaurants réputés gels et lili
propriétaire d'une grande entreprise de
boutiques de vêtements et jerry est l'un
des plus grands producteurs de légumes
au canada leurs affaires vont très bien
jusqu'au vendredi 13 13 mars 2020
le samedi c'était moi et mes médecins
résidents s'étaient moins cinq ans le
betis et et - 80 et le mardi on est
béant négatif du million les nouveaux
modèles à partir du début du confinement
et pendant des mois on a suivi de
l'intérieur des entrepreneurs ou bord du
précipice
on vous présente ce soir leurs
confidences tout au long de leur combat
pour sauver leur entreprise
j'y crois pas non j'y crois pas loin de
ce qui s'en vient pour nous c'est comme
a lâché un système digestif les emprunts
car pendant qu'on fait des milliers de
mises à pied que plusieurs se demandent
comment ils vont gagner leur vie
la coved vient faucher bien plus que des
ambitions d'affaires on vous présente
cette semaine le québec inc
comme vous ne l'avez jamais vu ici marie
maude denis
bienvenue à anka
pour suivre les instructions de la santé
publique
thiennes tradition de deux nouveaux
chili pour culminer des finances
achètent des chenilles et puis cette
année on l'encouragé la compagnie fadila
kébé grosse tournée nationale
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il ya un tempête de neige comme seul
québec que peuvent faire les marchés
boursiers en baisse de 8%
cette journée l'eau pour lundi est ce
qu'au niveau est ce qu ont fait le
spectacle et les patins et puis il du
monde qui tirerait l'usap comme ça le
montant précis quand lucho et moi j'ai
dit si on envoie le signal population
qu'on respecte pas la tradition tpiy son
hip hop au monsieur le président c'est
avec une grande fierté que je présente
aujourd'hui le deuxième budget du
gouvernement de la coalition à venir
québec le jet à faire avec des damnés de
la mi février on était au plein emploi
ont plein de connaître donné quand même
exceptionnel mais amanda la dépression
au nord on a mis en en cas de vie pour
10 rebonds mais lol ou de nuages
on en est conscient et des substituts
mais on n'est jamais rentré dans une
situation et certaines comme celle là en
aussi bonne posture
il y en a qui devait l'encadrer des
troupes et smith y en a qui aurait voulu
que l'académie soit pris note
le mercredi soir on est caucus et dans
l'autre homme annonce que l'ief lee vol
d'europe ne sont plus autorisés en
amérique
je suis pleinement conscient qu'on est
pas du tout dans le même environnement
dans lequel le budget des plaques
je sais que ça va être difficile il que
les chevaux gênés dans une récession
chaque session lorsqu'on est dans la
récession
ce n'est pas ce soir
ôtez les gens tout québec aussi mettre
en mots tour des consommateurs ont
dévalisé les étagères des épiceries en
raison des craintes liées au corps
navires us alimentation important mais
finalement ça a été je souhaiterais
qu'on a dit c'est pas normal
les indices étaient moindres est
maintenant chez des moins cinq ans le
betis été moins 80 et le mardi on était
en négatif tandis que les clients qui
héberge qui pourra les en croire sport
vacances on down in stone on va
sérieusement mais c'est là qu'on n'est
plus une addition de fermer les magasins
on était sur une bonne lancée depuis
l'automne dernier il a le fret est
vraiment bien parti
et puis nous voulons éviter de faire
braquer un espace de 72 pour tous
belhocine un avion en plus logique on
gère mais n'a pas de magasin et on se
ramasse ce qu'ont fait les autres 8 du
loup peut pas vers les deux héros xii a
rappelé que la décision s'est pris pour
les magasins l'édition civisme pour le
bureau qui m'insultent en 1650 personnes
à qui on ne pouvait pas imaginer une
puis s'était tapé a fait aujourd'hui
j'ai pris la décision de fermer toutes
les entreprises et tous les commerces
sauf pour les services essentiels dans
les faits
le québec doit être sur pause pendant
trois semaines direct le point de
bascule pour moi le plus dramatique ce
qu'un voleur on demande aux entreprises
le faire nous l'addition est venue de la
santé publique qui lie les ministres
économique on a été un peu surpris par
la vitesse de de l'annonce on peut le
dire que 40% de l'économie du québec est
arrêté
si sur l'état journée on est quatre le
moi j'ai un employé avec moi ni mon
garde du corps au 5e pile cheminer sur
une employée avec lui mais deux acteurs
clés du ministère des finances et
sous-ministre des menaces nous ont fait
continuellement des calculs de combien
l'économie bord souffre in puis combien
les finances publiques on three solos
ces deux questions là la c6 toujours
dans notre presse
[Musique]
les mardis à 13 5 1 toujours dans l'idée
dessus la crise est également des ligues
excite ajoute les niçois de revenir
on a trois ans de production en ligue 2
où on souhaite qu'elles québec
deviennent plus autonomes
on ne lit pas dans derniers mois que les
fruits les légumes qu'on importe ce
qu'on soit capable d amour
alors on utilise environ 180
travailleurs étrangers au la production
agricole
on a mené les travailleurs avec ceux qui
viennent travailler on rigole de
génériques ou insolites et au reggae
sont pas de coopi rigole-t-il de sucre
jean tardieu j'ai beau tout neuf à la
crise
quinn les succès pour le doubs mais
c'est sauvé parce que sélection d'erick
est un multi factorielle écouter pensez
quoi du pauvre dame venue au canada que
vous savez quand tu as personne personne
à mme diakité des masques et des deux
agneaux c'est parce sur ce masque cenco
años quasi temps l'offre sera quasi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
rectifié par les séquences assuré que
ces gens là nous ne se contaminent pour
ces travailleurs qui vivent quand même
eu dix bornes sont cinq à soixante mille
hommes pourquoi les arabes unis qu'ici
ça un peu son pc l'espagne affiche aussi
les couches minces
ça serait si l'on choisit demi j'ai 80
personnes à harar je sais pas mais reste
freiné sécurité
[Musique]
au retour l'angoissent monte d'un cran à
la proche de la saison touristique au
bas saint laurent
moi je n'aime pas manger au stylo le
valais vite que je trouve un moyen de
faire rentrer de l'argent sans attendre
d'après ces mesures
[Musique]
bon
le restaurant de tomber l'homme au
sahara
c'est avec mon chemin de la chef
propriétaire restant chez saint clair ça
fait 16 ans un peu encore comme une
femme chef en région le souhait de
dépenses évidemment premier rang de
venir m'installer ici parce que je
voulais une famille la fin est un peu
précaire des gens partant c'est pas
pâtir de la saint-jean-baptiste jusqu'à
la fin du travail c'est 80 % de notre
chiffre d'affaires
après ceux de tout ce que tu fais c'est
resté ouvert enfin vous faire de
l'argent tu paies des permis à l'année
qu'au dessus du loup le cas l'année mais
que d'un modèle la femme doit être
rentable sur une courte période
si tu veux des produits de la région
faut que tu les communs après il faut
que les achètent pas la porte car il ya
beaucoup de petits producteurs qui
dépendent de moi c'est de ce que moi je
vais acheter ces gens leur ont dû
continuer à produire tout l'hiver pour
pouvoir me fournir tout l'été parce que
et je viens avec un volume vraiment
impressionnant moi je peux passer
soixante dix à lyon en deux mois puis 0
après michel le principe à l'achat
c'est une fête
mocistes jamais notre et larry moss qui
chaque catastrophe et le lisez la
manière dont ce même pas son os pour y
aller la reine elizabeth à montréal ils
viennent de reinach et puis y'a personne
à l'hôtel biya pas très serein c'est
tragique
c'est clair pour moi que c'est
extrêmement important des carmes quand
tout le monde était nerveux
il faut aussi trouver mouillé de
ralentir les événements à ce que tous
vos vies justement veut prendre des
décisions rapidement
je suis très heureux de vous présenter
le programme des jo travailleurs à
faible revenu
notre gouvernement va également fournir
12 points 5 milliards de dollars
additionnels au total 250 millions
totalisent près de 11 milliards de
dollars cette allocation remplacera les
deux allocations qu'on a annoncé la
semaine dernière c'est sûr qu'il faut
aider les gens il faut aider les
entreprises et avant de faire des
annonces font les jambes on réfléchit
danger hostiles à aller vite que je
trouve un moyen de faire rentrer de
l'argent sans attendre après ces mesures
[Musique]
nous on va les paniers à la semaine on
transforme toutes nos légumes de garde
nous on continue d'acheter j'ai même
roulement que d'habitude moi c'est sûr
que c'est pas ça que j'avais dessiné
dans vie femmes prêtes à manger et on
fait environ à peu près de 20 et pias
manille qui on en fait 25 donc cest ou
pas on peut pas tenir comme ça
non non non non non non non non non non
c'est impossible
là on le fait le pas ce que tu es jeux
tout le monde cet accueil chez nous a
rien fait
donc aujourd'hui on annonce une
directive de la santé publique qui va
nous permettre de contrôler les
déplacements dans certaines régions
éloignées du québec et les gens ont
besoin des villes pour aller chercher
les fameux voyons voyons une touriste un
bonhomme mais comme damien bonhomme sait
si montréal restaient confinés parce que
c'est comme la grande question le
présentement 12 autres est ce que c'est
quand même 75 % de votre clientèle ou et
with a vraiment c'est ça c'est 75%
c'est sûr que si jamais c'est ça ben il
va falloir qu'on qu'on développe un
concept qui lui est vraiment et je
concentre vraiment sur une clientèle
locale
[Musique]
je rendrai dans l'entrepôt le même
talent
nous allons se passer on passe à combler
vérifie qu'une personne sur les éteindre
la barre de jéhovah ebe de vie aux
finances de ça donne un coup on peut
voir une entreprise décline sur des
années 90 ou mercredi a anéanti cia le
but y ait plus personne
c'est incroyable nous pouvons au cours
des 90
tu m'as fait you finances qui fait du
tort de projection il ya un an sont les
indiens ne vous concernant 6 millions là
qu'ils vont envoyer une
notre valeur dans les magasins ces
listes
ce que les manques kananga lentilles
l'esa nom de tout du goût stocks nulle
et on veut prudent c'est à peu près les
façons les plus imaginer qu'on peut
montrer la violence avec laquelle saisie
plus il ya des bois s'adapter pour les
magasins lendemain sont stockés dans
palais ici à matin le camion vient de
ramener ça c'est des chargements qui se
destinait au magasin que les ouvrages on
a dû porter et puis que dit marguerite a
fermé un désastre tendant normal
personne n'accepterait pas ça de dans
les à lille la circulation six cultes
août alors qu'on a pu l'être qu'on
m'aide stagné venus de toute façon j'ai
pu employer ce qu'on le reçoit quand mes
coups du marché ainsi que les émissions
financière profitant pas d'opération là
pour dévier du cochon
le nom est bien conscient de si ça joue
dur lors d'une économie au monde le sait
pas
est ce qu'aujourd'hui vous vous demandez
c'est tristan peut survivre à cette
crise
bien heureusement on peut pas passer le
mot d mais on dit que on et off après la
pause se réinventer pour survivre
tristan se lance dans les visières et
dans le vide
une fois le choc passé nos entrepreneurs
vont se retrousser les manches
tristan se lance dans la fabrication
d'équipements médicaux mais c'est un
grand pari financièrement la deuxième
nation la france dans le monde a
organisé point du vix a eu de bonnes
informations
on nous disait que c'est une vision qui
manquait une amie elle qui lui a dit
écoutez nous on a plus de visière et
dans le système de santé
ils vont marquer êtes vous capable d'en
faire et on est parti de ça alors on
était à table à la mairie où sid
lorsque nous serons tous conçus par mars
mormal à la limite elle l'ultime manche
manger ici et puis pour le mi6 et puis
on commence à parler de place et on
appelle du jeune à coke yeux puisque
nordiques ou pas le tarif plastique
qu'on a toujours pareil dit m
bien on parle de place et puis dès la
stupide de fonte et toutes des matériaux
avec lesquels on est pas familier de
jours l'atelier en avait on avait trop
tôt type dans les médias et finances du
soir aura lieu
c'est seulement une hypothèse là on est
occupé en coupe on compte à tous mais
divise yen à l'auto en revenant forte
aux médecins et à leurs maisons en libye
on y va chaque jour tout le monde nous
prédit appel alors ça nous tient la
musique m'a appelé ce matin qu'ils
n'apprennent plus rire vous les lisez
qu'on faisait plus des commandes de 100
une témoin et des photos et jusqu'à
l'hôpital solaire comment les melons
dans le plus dimanche sur la route tous
les jours on est jusqu'à 90 jusqu'à on y
compte un droit en sautant dans cette
histoire de visière parce que ça nous
empêche de sauvegarde du bateau coule et
puis de capter de la demande du mois le
toit après
étape 1 est-ce que tu en as besoin 205
en une fois ou si on prête livré en deux
deux fois c'était tellement difficile
d'être conservé les usines dans les
dernières années on s'est posé des
questions ce qui c'était difficile de
garder la main d'oeuvre
chaque nouvelle demain qu'on a on
réalise que si on n'avait pas les usines
ici qu'entouraient rapport un pire
aucune demande on pourrait aider la
manière dont on fait en ce moment
oui aujourd'hui vendredi j'ai pas mal
mais s'en vont à l'hôpital de rimouski
la qualité totale
alors si tu prends ta fait jusqu'à
vendredi après midi pour la laiterie
temps pour l'un des crimes les moins mal
tu as fait comme ses deux premiers il ya
consensus user mais je vais m'y verrais
personnel
tellement l'édifice hier d'un modem
alors que tout le monde n'a été
bénéficiaire en battant le taupe et
jaune pour saint-orens sauvage puis
henri 4 millions ce soit en huit autres
systèmes à l'abri des usines auraient
atteint là tout le travail accompli pour
analyser on a mis une sécurité pour
s'assurer de leioa mahdi dit l'imam en
effet inclinés 9 ans les 200
travailleurs habré qui sont des gens et
jaugeant réals
tout redevenait je viens ici on est tous
bien conscients s'arrêter un jour le
secon classe à moins qu'eric reste
confinée sinon un jour miss avoir mes
factures commun on est capable de gérer
la pénurie d'équipements de protection
est maintenant bien réel pour certains
équipements on a un ordre pour trois à
sept jours
ottawa n'a pas reçu le 10
des centaines de millions de masques qui
n'a commandé mais on cherche des
millions de masques et devant cette
pénurie bien les etats-unis ont décidé
de ne plus fournir la planète si elles
ne sont qu on tire de la crise actuelle
c'est qu'on devrait autonome pour les
pieds qui sont essentiels public main
médicale c'est un bien essentiel pour
accélérer le processus et puis pour
venir en aide aux gens qui en ont
vraiment besoin d'un système de la santé
que pour qu'on ait produit au moment où
ils en ont besoin et on a décidé de se
commettre que d'acheter le matériel
avant même d'avoir confirmation quant
aux prix qui sera payé par le client
fait remarquer on a encore de
l'expertisé d'un secteur du textile mais
le défi c'est d'avoir eu le dessus
aujourd'hui vous avez probablement pas
mais y'a parler précisément d'être
suffisant on al'expertise au québec mais
on n'est juste pas les chutes alors neuf
vous vous êtes là puis vous vous allez
près l'arrivée la mise d'un jour j'ai
dit gm sort il ne répondrait pas à
quatre jours de la semaine
d'affrontements sont alors lui c'est un
pied ou par deux mais il faut partir de
mec moi j'ai payé au plus vite pour le
poker
[Musique]
tout est enfin là et tout est fait il y
en a tout le monde sort de là dessus
depuis
si on peut faire quelque chose là c'est
comme l argent avant la décision avant
46 500 voix l'ex vas-y parce que les
autoradios des messages ou death coil à
cinq couleurs disponibles grâce aux pubs
le pardon n'est plus pareil
on a réservé mais par le temps qu'on
envoie le paiement ils ont vendu à
quelqu'un d'autre
comment le livre se lit à la crise
baissions vd ya dix mois que j'attendais
une bombe elle en aime ça
[Musique]
péladeau n'est qu'avant mais nouvelle
médaille c'était bien sûr se lever et
sans les ami e s
et puis moi je serai pas dans la data
c'est bien le cas dit gino c'est un peu
de bon sens j'habite au cambodge tout
croche ans ne posséderait sottise notre
médical mais je peux vous dire que les
tuniques en étant rétablie comme sur les
25 restants jusqu'à complète si je mets
des champions vont appeler on va vous
envoyer jambes rire et photos à normande
leurs besoins et tellement urgent qui
nous ont emmenés accélérer le délai de
production
on va faire tous les pantalons dans
notre usine et tous les autres ont fait
chez notre sous traitants alors combien
tu en veux que je te prépares de top 105
102 ans les hôpitaux en fait nous
demande de ne pas attendre d'avoir leur
quantité complète de livrer au fur et à
mesure alors comme je sais qu'un hôpital
et amende de ce mal dont j'aime avec la
production commence par le soin de toi
donné que je suis en fait avec une
couture française n'était pas de calais
jean louis pour être mieux mais c'est à
dire on est vu le ver cible
oui mais oui je sais pas pourquoi je
pense pas qu'il y mettre parce qu elle
peut élever les bars garde soit de la
veille j'ai entendu les fonds de ce test
étant capable de faire les choses avec
un équipe qui se font non seulement
voter de la cover flow
100 artistes comme on le redit il est
passé beaux-arts nous appeler parce
qu'ils sont en situation d'urgence comme
ressource illimitée
1 chaque mois de fermeture va nous
coûter 3 % pib et à quoi le sme
hâtivement 5 milliards de financements
et essor moi j'ai vu sur première j'ai
dit aux autres ministres mais du patio
pour qu'on ouvre un mot plus je veux
juste que tout le monde sache que la
différence entre ouvrir le 15 mai puis
ouvrir le 15 juin mais c'est
l'indifférence à -12 un déficit qui
m'ont d'abord il est possible qu'on nous
les écoles à partir du 4 mai c'est pas
exclu on annonce que l'on ferme jusqu'au
1er mai les gens pensent que par exemple
c'est moi puis fatigué même du poste
pourrait ouvrir
je vous dirais que le ministre qui veut
être le plus favorable à l'ouverture
c'est le ministériel qu'armand le
ministre carmin et pour un minus qui
tape sur la table qui tirait ou vendre
les biens nous fait tous les enjeux de
santé publique n'est clairement
on est un responsable la dpj la sortie
matin il plus proche des effets négatifs
du confinement dans travail qu'est ce
que vous dites peut-être contrairement à
la perception populaire la pression
qu'on vient pas des ministères
économiques je pense que tout le monde
souhaitait ouvrir mon mais pas de prêt
si on prend des décisions aux calculs et
on est conscient qu'il y pop des comptes
si on veut avancer les pieds ajusté dans
le caucus des 76 députés qui sont reçues
à paris par où citoyens à tous les jours
qu'ils ont les inquiétudes quilico g2
téléphone le personnel professionnel
puis j'ai un député qui me texte sur un
téléphone pour un groupe de pression
j'en ai un autre qui me texte ou un
autre groupe de pression
ma réponse dans les deux cas c est ce qu
ont perdu leur emploi et est ce qu'ils
ont perdu parce que tout le monde c'est
difficile pour tout le monde
la situation m'ayant novo qui s'y plient
difficile le faux faux faux xi je pense
ouvrir les flammes qui regardent yves si
vous êtes propriétaire d'un magasin de
nous tels deux stars d'un bord d'une
salle de spectacles d'une troupe de
théâtre c'est beaucoup plus dur que si
vous aimez marchés d'alimentation là et
on a obtenu l'autorisation sûreté
publique pour annoncer graduellement et
de façon sécuritaire
la l'ouverture de notre économie chez a
précisé que la direction santé publique
et si que la cnss est et oui la borie
des règles très claires que toutes les
entreprises autorisées à ouvrir doivent
ont respecté en tous points
j'ai jeu sera sue les laits le projet
préliminaire des masos
d'hygiène à respecter pour une
réouverture à 50%
c'est de ça qu'on parle puis j'ai tourné
les pages le titre un projet lé 6 à 8
pages et je regardais ça c'est là que je
me suis dit la semaine passée
ok jean marc collat c'est comme même
arraché tout un système digestif les
avril carlo thill désiré j'y crois pas
non j'y crois pas là de ce qui s'en
vient pour nous qu'en restaurant de 50
places à qui tu dis mais maintenant que
je dois à 25 places
on dit toujours le cil 30e clients qui
commence à être payant fait que dans le
fond tout ce qu'on va faire le sait
payer des factures puisse brûler c'est
ça c'est ça qu'on nous demande de faire
est ce que vous êtes un vrai de dire que
chez celles qui pourraient ne pas être
rouvert cet été ouais ouais pays toile
de l'hamza agir seul
parce que
on n'est pas immortel
c'est le fait que je dirais la même
chose de rester à rentrer on n'est pas
immortel
au retour c'est le début du
déconfinement qui va rouvrir et qui
restera fermée
il sonne le chiot extrêmement difficile
[Musique]
oui je sais que tu as un attrait
particulier pour les restaurateurs
on va aller parler à une chef qu'on
connaît bien
colombe st pierre a décidé cette année
de ne pas ouvrir ta salle à manger
pourquoi mais j'ai beaucoup pleuré la
semaine passée et parce que je dis je
dis non je m'en veux en même temps je me
dis voyante depuis ghost writer mais que
tout ce qu'on a bâtie s'écroule ça sinon
on va essayer de s'en sortir
gmail est quelque chose de brisé le
petit âne et le fais je vous aviez 20
pourquoi il faut pas rêver
c'est indéniable on sait que tous les
commerces tous les auteurs tous les
restaurants toutes les salles
inspecteurs lorsqu'on pas top
je pense que les jeunes intérim ou stylo
il y aurait probablement est confiné les
commerces à 24 ou caucus on ressent
toujours la distinction
morial région on la sait au niveau
économique on l'as un haut niveau
l'immigration on a ça au niveau de la
place du français situé à montréal vers
ce serait du québec
les pétitions ont été lancées dans
plusieurs régions du québec pour
empêcher l'accès aux visiteurs qui
proviennent de l'extérieur de montréal
notamment au civil a commis 19
j'attends tout si beaucoup en fait
semaine des gens qui habitent palangre à
montréal qui ont peur de dire non
réalisables dans notre région d'où une
pétition signée par des milliers de
personnes réclament le report de la
levée du barrage du parc des laurentides
gpo cli québécois commencent à chaque
année plus divisée entre montréal puis
le moment beaucoup de faux débats au
site
cette crise là un espace de gages
ici on veut pouvoir éléments real et
puis là il ya du monde cik impressionne
c'est finalement la motta entretiennent
ça mais on est vraiment là là c'est par
contre ce que j'ai compris dans cette
crise là c'est une grosse partie tels
d'affaires relevait du touriste c'est
positif aussi parce que moi ça me ferait
prendre des décisions leur vie afin
qu'ils soient trop table construire
quelque chose qui est qui est viable
tourisme ont pas tourisme pour le
commerce de détail partout au québec
sauf dans la communauté métropolitaine
de montréal cmm les commerces de détail
qui ont une entrée directe à l'extérieur
pourront rouvrir à compter de lundi
le 4 mai par contre les centres
commerciaux avec des aires communes
devons demeurer fermées jusqu'à nouvel
ordre
on n'est pas des magasins brisant en et
dimaga et sen d'achat des moeurs auquel
le ministre quand il décide quelque
chose de facile curiosité de chacun
le tchèque qui nous appellent m 2
environ 3 x a du bon sens pas de bon
sens le moineau je me lamente à
carrefour laval où on regardait fermé
mais par césar un portrait extérieur
vauvray il y aura deux trois semaines
d'avancé
ouais c'est un compétiteur énorme il
sonne le chiot extrêmement difficile
c'était une excellente exagéré clicquot
mersen à une scène d'un chiot trouve
plus
et si c'est le cas on est obligé de
faire des arbitrages
il a en hainaut adoré la magasin mais
avec un moment où il ya des barrages
vous dit qu'un machin là on peut pas y
aller
une vingtaine d'années passées
[Musique]
on choqué c'est seulement parce que
savoir fois ci juste dit les centaures
au port ses phares mais datant des
collections baron reprendre tous mes
remerciements jo sont pour les
entrepreneurs du québec
donc je vous dis que ça soit un
investissement québec où que ce soit
aussi votre banque ou votre caisse on va
tout faire pour vous aider
financièrement à passer au travers
les banques qui au début on pensait
qu'ils allaient la bonne mère tolérance
au risque
l'on s'aperçoit qu'après quelques
semaines de négociations s'est pas
encore mais c'est à dire que par exemple
quoi on voudra pas vous donner plus de
marge de crédit ou vous avancez défaut
ou est-ce que c'est comme ça qu'on s'est
elle-même en retirer va donner ni les
chefs ok pour garder le 9.5 millions
j'ai dit stock de la valeur au coût de
15 millions belle diva l'on cautionne
par dessus alors il me tend liste des
galas immobilières et des signatures
personnelles puis tout ce que tu veux je
dis et snacks dans le fracas du tout
ces problèmes que vous allez utiliser la
période la pandémie pour neil nous
attacher un moulin ou couleur pour le
reste allongement ça m'a choqué c'est
terriblement déçu aussi forte soit le
sort est épouvantable tout le monde
votre service pour vous qui on va tous
les goûts du manga permet magasin où on
joue vraiment vos écrans bien passé mais
là faut je ne sache où et quoi les
observe à ce point si on y réfléchit
jour et nuit son contrôle des solutions
il faut qu'on trouve une solution
j'ai des containers par deux chiens ga
des employés d'entrepôts g les factures
sont payées au pays tout le monde
atteint il semble d'ailleurs à temps
tout le monde à table à son check raisé
métier chez cnet a sorti là ça va aller
diriger la marque de crédit qui n'existe
plus seul ben ne puis le mage
[Musique]
alors qu'on le dit c'est triste un
combat découvert équipe y compris les
mesures pour se financer à yahoo a tué
leurs fonctions chez papa c'est sûr
[Musique]
dans un instant quand la qu'ovide fera
pâle usine qui tous et sans avoir les
cinq ans
[Musique]
il devrait s'arrêter ce catch à
m'excuser à m'expliquer quel soyez 15
que caresser sa série derrière de lui
l'été la région puis la plupart en ce
moment ça c'est normal mais il vaut ce
père si oui j'ai eu assez de fait que
les mecs quai ils sont heureux de lire
aux yeux des gens euros puis c'est quoi
qui fait fi reçu plusieurs courriels de
gens de la région de kidal on souhaite
c'est correct et haïdara y en a qui
viennent pas des rallyes vous avez des
gens qui ont commencé à vous écrire pour
vous dire pas de problème si vous avez
des mexicains mais on veut pas tous les
voir dans nos commerces devrait faire
quoi
[Musique]
le travail c'est quoi au dernier l'état
d'esprit des couples d'autres concepts
une semaine montrent qu'en fin de
journée la victoire
puissamment pour le teint qui est il
lors d'événements qui quitta n y en eu
lieu parce que le sang peut provenir
pour elie que tu es sérieux que ça lui
suffit pas si le directeur de production
tu as même ce mystérieux de l'hygiène
beauté aux états unis de l'autre comme
le modèle exact mais sans livrer de
l'eau
[Musique]
thorzain s'est plaint comme si c'était
qu'on revoie l'icis au clash et par luzy
elle accouche ilic par ledit glas du
tout c'est une fois ou deux qui sentait
fatigué 8 à tour organisé je pense
quelque chose comme ce johnny cependant
mes jambes m'ont fait me lâcher je puis
vous venez là je ris pour toi
s'assombrir à john le litre à 100 tout
le temps ces deux roues ils sont votre
charme aussi avec quelques septembre
vendredi à ce que je vis contenu grâce
aux dons y avait envoyé sa femme les
voies pierra menta manger ça va mal de
vue qui tout chez lui dans quel sens
anglais envoient les septembre donc si
on veut une nouvelle
bon il ya d'autres nouvelles qui le
liait au premier regard inédit dans la
police
ils ont les pouvoirs sont la porter
[Musique]
sur ces quelques 155 en deux dans le
deuxième puis si meghaoui de cuir tout
inquiète tout le monde ce qui fait
courir sa filiale c'est bien q le
personnel ce matin tout le monde ce taux
monte à leurs proches mais bon avec
beaucoup d qu'il se la traversée pour
terminer entente qui soit je redis
encore quasiment les rivages quatre ans
enlevée par ariane on savait qu'une
union
poux
vous allez le voir nos entrepreneurs ne
sont pas au bout de leurs épreuves ni de
leurs émotions en montagnes russes on
vous a préparé une deuxième partie dont
voici un avant-goût
je sentais que le confinement des
propriétaires ou sérieux pigeon d'avoir
des caries ça soit pas suffisant pour
qu'on fait s'en sortir il nous faut
quelque chose
nous on a perdu des millions nous
perdrons poignée ton père tu y en a vu
y'a du 210 au caire c'est un rendez vous
pour la deuxième partie de ce reportage
d'ici là merci beaucoup d'avoir été là à
la semaine prochaine
[Musique]